[Applaudissements]
j'ai un coeur en mousse c'est une jolie
phrase pour commencer un thé beeksma
mais c'est vrai en plus sur les passants
à leurs bonbons je suis né avec une
malformation cardiaque et deux mois
après ma naissance
on m'a ouvert le coeur on a réparé ce
qui n'allait pas et on a juste mis un
petit bout de mousse sans lequel je
serai pas là pour vous parler
aujourd'hui j'ai 22 ans et malgré tout
ça c'est seulement maintenant que j'ai
pris conscience de la chance que j'ai
d'être vivant quand j'étais petit je
pensais qu'à cause de ce choeur en
mousse je n'arriverai à ressentir aucune
émotion
sauf que c'était tout le contraire je
ressentais beaucoup trop d'émotions et
j'avais un besoin constant de les
exprimer
c'était comme respirer pour moi moi ça
ne dérangeait pas
et par contre ça m'a très vite amené à
connaître leur enseignement scolaire
parce que j'étais en opposition à la
masse que la masse elle est jouée à la
loi du plus fort et que le plus fort
c'est celui qui montrait pas ses
émotions
alors
tout fait j'ai tout fait pour que ça
s'arrête j'ai essayé d'entretenir des
relations conventionnelles avec les gens
j'arrivais le matin et je pouvais juste
dire salut ça va on a quoi comme cours
aujourd'hui
et ça se serait arrêtée là je pouvais
pas parce que c'était pas moi ça moi
j'arrivais je disais bonjour
j'espère que tu vas bien mais après je
peux comprendre
je peux comprendre que ce soit dur d'
exprimer ses émotions
mais bon quand même quoi ah bon et donc
ça a compliqué les choses et j'ai tout
connu cette peur dans chaque couloir
chaque salle de cours ce bruit constant
dans votre dans vos oreilles
cette sensation qu'on parle dans votre
dos qu'on vous juge à chaque instant
j'étais en équilibre sur le fil le plus
fin du monde
et quand j'ai découvert ma sexualité et
qui les ont découvert ma sexualité y
avait plus l'équilibré je pouvais plus
rien faire face à des gens qui
comprenait pas comment je pouvais
ressentir de telles émotions pour eux
j'ai un ami
c'est annie s'appelle bilal et donc si
vous voulez bien on va dire bonjour
bilal
voilà et bilal à chaque fois que je le
vois il me fait maxime tu es beau maxime
je t'aime et salif et ce à toutes les
cinq minutes un toutes les cinq minutes
thébaux je t'aime et je suis fasciné par
sa capacité à exprimer ses émotions et à
dire ce qu'il ressent à aller chercher
au plus profond de lui cette petite
chose et de l'exprimer pleinement au
grand jour c'est dur c'est dur à faire
et vous savez ce qui est bien c'est
qu'on a des lieux pour ça on a des
scènes de concerts on a nos réseaux
sociaux on a sauté l'x ici aujourd'hui
et puis on a les salles de cinéma la
première fois que mes parents me l'ont
emmené j'ai su que je voudrais plus
jamais repartir c'était comme si la
salle me parle et qu'elle me disait tout
va bien ici tu peux ressentir ce que tu
veux tu peux rire tu peux pleurer
on n'est pas là pour juger personne de
verre tu es juste dans l'obscurité de la
salle avec la lumière de l'écran étape
avoir honte tu sais pourquoi parce que
les gens qui sont autour de toi ils sont
aussi là pour ça
c'est peut-être pour ça que mes parents
m'y emmener pour la première fois j'ai
toujours eu du mal à communiquer mes
émotions et avec l'adolescence avec
toute cette violence
avec toutes ces tous et toutes
toutes ces nouvelles questions sur ma
sexualité
je n'arrivais plus à l'est vers et puis
avait le cinéma avec le cinéma je
pouvais leur parler que ce soit un film
de trente ans que j'avais vu la veille
vous de celui qui allait sortir dans
deux semaines que j'attendais avec
impatience
c'était comme si comme si pour arriver à
communiquer mes émotions avec eux je
passais par celle qu'on ressentait en
regardant le film et que ça faisait un
pont entre nous alors quand j'ai arrêté
mes études à 18 ans que j'ai été brisé
par la scolarité par toute cette haine
que j'avais pris dans la gueule je
n'arrivais plus à communiquer avec les
gens
j'avais plus exprimé à n'importe qui ce
que je ressentais alors j'ai décidé de
faire pareil qu'avec mes parents j'ai
décidé de faire mes propres films pour
créer un pont avec eux j'ai lancé ma
petite chaîne youtube à mon nom parce
que je ne suis pas quelqu'un de très
original
je vais donc appeler maxime grandjean et
j'ai commencé par faire quelques jolies
petites vidéos je filmais des gay pride
est joli ciel bleu et les gens qui
regardaient ces vidéos me disais wow
c'est beau ce que tu fais ta vie doit
être tellement heureuse
j'étais là et je me disais non
non je vais pas bien je suis rempli
doute de névrose qui ne perd constante
du vide de la bande
si bien de respirer j'avais j'avais mal
j'avais mal parce que je portais depuis
des années des douleurs dont je
n'arrivais pas à me débarrasser et
j'avais besoin de les extérioriser alors
j'ai décidé de relever de commencer à
vraiment me reconstruire j'ai fait
quelques petites vidéos sur le
harcèlement scolaire et j'ai tout lâché
j'ai toute cette violence cette haine ce
dégoût qu'on veut vous faire ressentir
j'ai tout mais j'ai partagé mon
expérience aux autres je me suis libéré
d'un poids
après que j'ai sorti ses vidéos un
ancien de mon collège est venu me parler
et il m'a dit tu sais j'étais harcelée
je t'ai fait du mal mais c'est pourquoi
parce que j'avais la même sexualité que
toi en opposition à la masse et je n'ai
pas envie qu'on me frappe alors j'ai
joué à la loi du plus fort c'est toi que
j'ai frappé jeter
ap ap un plaisir j'étais à prêt parce
que j'avais peur vous avez vu comme
c'est vicieux s'est vu comme c'est
vicieux comment la violence se crée
davantage c'est qu'ici on vous avait dit
on vous a dit que vous étiez spectateurs
mais aussi acteur j'aimerais faire un
appel qui est une épreuve à passer une
épreuve qu'il faut passer je voudrais
inviter des gens à faire comme moi à
prendre conscience de la peur et à se
relever si des personnes ici ont été
victimes du harcèlement scolaire
si les mêmes des personnes noires se
l'est parce qu'il voulait pas que ce
soit eux qui soient harcelées voudrais
juste que ces personnes se lèvent
six personnes se lève c'est pas grave
mais si des personnes ont été victimes
de harcèlement scolaire
je les invite à se lever ici et
maintenant je vais déjà une personne qui
s'élevait une autre au fond
la cie
merci à vous merci à ceux qui sont le
[Applaudissements]
vis comme c'est du rhin se lever c'est
aussi dur d'exprimer nos émotions quand
cette personne est venue me raconter son
histoire
je me suis rendu compte que moi aussi
j'avais peur j'avais toujours cette peur
de communiquer mes émotions aux gens qui
me sont chers j'ai décidé de changer ça
j'ai commencé depuis quelques temps un
vrai travail pour aller de plus en plus
vers le j'ai des idées en faisant ça
d'envoyer un message à ceux qui
voulaient me rabaisser vous pensez que
je pourrais pas avoir d'amis vous pensez
que j'étais mort pour tout ce que vous
avez dit penser que je serai toujours
tout seul
non j'ai mes amis autour de moi autour
de mon contenu
j'ai réussi à rassembler presque 9000
personnes que je voudrais évidemment
tout remercier ce soir et surtout je
suis vivant je suis là
et là vous pourriez vous dire ah c'est
ça qui lui a fait prendre conscience
qu'il était vivant et l'a pas encore non
non non non non non ce qui m'a fait
prendre conscience de ça c'est que je me
suis pas relever tout seul je me suis
pas reconstruit tout seul j'avais mes
proches autour de moi mes amis ma
famille ils étaient là ils ont toujours
été là et j'ai jamais eu la force de les
remercier pour ça donc déjà je voudrais
faire ce soir
et ensuite je voudrais vous appelez à
faire quelque chose quand vous sortirez
de sata dicks vous allez appeler
quelqu'un qui compte pour vous allez lui
envoyer un message vous allez lui dire
tout ce que vous ressentez pour aller
pour lui vous allez dire tout ce que
j'avais au fond du coeur votre petit
coeur aux mousses et vous allez lui dire
ce que vous avez jamais réussi à lui
dire ce que vous ressentez au plus
profond de vous j'ai 22 ans
et grâce à ce coeur en mousse depuis
tout ce temps je peux me lever tous les
matins et être avec les gens qui
comptent pour moi ils sont là ils sont
dans ma vie et ils font ma vie les avoir
à mes côtés
c'est ça qui m'a fait prendre conscience
de la chance que j'ai d'être vivant
[Applaudissements]